la cumbre de las américas volvió al país
en el que nació eeuu y la ciudad de los
ángeles acogió a los jefes de estado y
de gobierno de nuestros países
bienvenidos a california para esta
emisión especial de aquí américa
dedicada al encuentro de nuestro
continente
invocando el espíritu de unión de
1994 cuando se celebró la primera cumbre
de las américas en la ciudad también
estadounidense de miami el presidente
joe biden quiso resarcir años de lejanía
con los líderes de nuestro continente y
lo logró a pesar de las marcadas
ausencias de algunos presidentes ya sea
porque no asistieron o porque no fueron
invitados la declaración de los ángeles
contiene acuerdos tangibles en varias
materias
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
anunció un acuerdo para dar inicio a las
negociaciones de la alianza de las
américas para la prosperidad económica
el próximo mes de octubre una zona de
libre comercio entre iguales un acuerdo
económico que también se invocó hace 28
años durante la primera cumbre de las
américas celebrada bajo la
administración de bill clinton pero que
nunca vio la luz con esta declaración
estamos transformando nuestro enfoque de
la gestión de la migración en las
américas cada uno de nosotros está
firmando compromisos que reconocen los
desafíos que todos compartimos y la
responsabilidad de los impactos de todas
nuestras naciones james jones sin dejar
claros los lineamientos la declaración
final de los ã ngeles establece
propuestas genéricas para cooperar
económicamente y reforzar el banco
interamericano de desarrollo en materia
de medio ambiente la declaración de los
ángeles logró además que cinco países de
la región trabajen con los 15 miembros
actuales de la iniciativa de energía
renovable para américa latina y el
caribe la relax para tener el 70 por
ciento de la capacidad para producir
energía renovable para 2030 y un
compromiso para prevenir futuras
pandemias con un plan de formación de
500 mil personas como personal médico
especialmente para atender emergencias
en poblaciones rurales así como un
compromiso de 9 países para proteger los
océanos conocido como la hermandad que
busca crear la zona de reserva de los
océanos más grandes del mundo
[Música]
y el único anuncio tangible de la
declaración de los ángeles es el acuerdo
de las américas para la migración que
incluye un compromiso de inversión
privada de estadounidense de 1900
millones de dólares específicamente para
el triángulo norte de centroamérica así
como un protocolo de ayuda para los
países que reciben migrantes y una
gestión de las fronteras previo al
anuncio y en coincidencia con el inicio
de esta cumbre de las américas una nueva
caravana de migrantes partido desde
honduras y hasta allí llegaron nuestros
enviados especiales
con los pies inflamados y el estómago
vacío
llegaron los miles de emigrantes a
pernoctar en huixtla 50 kilómetros al
norte de tapachula la ciudad fronteriza
del sur de méxico donde nunca más
esperan volver
pero los niños a las 5 de la mañana ya
los niños ambos mitad y mitad 50
kilómetros que ésta pedía ahí para acá
para que no vengan a darle té
una tarjeta de paso prácticamente un
salvoconducto porque no fue ni una vez
este es el documento que a franklin como
a miles de emigrantes le negaron en
tapachula y sin el cual quedan expuestos
a ser capturados y deportados por los
agentes de inmigración
[Música]
ahora en huixtla las oficinas de aduana
están desbordadas y día tras día se ven
aglomeraciones de personas desesperadas
por obtener el documento peor aún para
los migrantes haitianos y africanos que
no dominan el español actuamos con sala
cuando andrés de ese cielo para pie
salimos hace tres meses de áfrica y
llevamos una semana aquí esperando el
documento y por fin hoy nos lo
entregaron queremos ir a eeuu
amamos eeuu y vamos para allá a hacer
nuestra vida o me patinaba o para tíffer
en otro fila baja
cae la noche y se sublevan los ánimos
hay malestar en el ambiente
todavía son entre 7000 y 8000 los
migrantes de la caravana que aguardan el
pase migratorio para gozar de 30 días de
legalidad y aún así es un tiempo
insuficiente para los que no tienen
dinero en el bolsillo porque tendrán que
trabajar para conseguir los costosos
boletos de autobús que los transporten
hasta su destino final a más de 2.200
kilómetros la frontera sur de eeuu
[Música]
una cumbre marcada por las ausencias
específicamente por la decisión del
presidente de eeuu joe biden de no
incluir en la lista de invitados a los
representantes de cuba de venezuela y de
nicaragua por considerar que no tienen
prácticas democráticas pero los que sí
llegaron hasta aquí específicamente a
una de las calles más emblemáticas de la
ciudad de los ángeles ponen los
representantes de la sociedad civil para
pedir que se incluya en la declaración
final de esta cumbre de las américas una
resolución de condena a los presidentes
de estos tres países
100 nuevas estrellas en el paseo de la
fama por los presos políticos de
venezuela cuba y nicaragua con este acto
simbólico familiares de los detenidos
pidieron a los jefes de estado y de
gobierno reunidos en la cumbre de las
américas que en la declaración final se
incluyera una petición a los presidentes
nicolás maduro miguel díaz canel y
daniel ortega por su liberación en
kuwait más de 1200 presos políticos hay
más presos políticos que en el resto del
continente todos sumados pero en
nicaragua y en venezuela juntos también
hay alrededor de 500 presos políticos
esas son las verdaderas estrellas de
américa latino y por eso estamos aquí en
el paseo de las estrellas contándole a
todo el que pasa que es importante
exigir la liberación inmediata de cada
uno de los que en nuestros países está
preso por demandar libertad si bien en
este punto no se incluyó en la
declaración final la necesidad de que en
los pueblos de las américas haya respeto
por los derechos humanos y el estado de
derecho fue escuchada al menos con la
decisión de eeuu a pesar del boicot
iniciado por el presidente mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador de no
invitar a los jefes de venezuela
nicaragua y cuba lo que llevó a que
durante varias semanas la cumbre
estuviera amenazada al finalizar el
evento de eeuu anunció que destinará 314
millones de dólares adicionales de ayuda
humanitaria para venezolanos que se
encuentran en su propio país y para los
inmigrantes y refugiados en varios
países de américa latina' el
departamento de estado anunció además
que destinará 103 millones de dólares en
proyectos de acceso a la salud ya la
educación para los venezolanos en 17
países de la región entre ellos
argentina república dominicana méxico
paraguay perú y uruguay el departamento
de estado recordó además que más de 6
millones de venezolanos han abandonado
su país desde 2015
la novena cumbre de las américas llegó a
los ángeles con un año de retraso debido
a la pandemia del cob y 19 el próximo
encuentro debería tener lugar en 2025 y
allá los líderes deberán evaluar si los
compromisos adquiridos en la ciudad de
los ángeles se mueven hacia hacer una
realidad gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión especial de aquí américa desde
los ángeles california sigan con más en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom